hey this is presh talwalkar
problematic men is a korean tv show
where contestants solve puzzles
several contestants have iqs above 150
which is commonly referred to as the
genius level
one episode featured the following
puzzle
and one contestant suho solved it in
less than one minute
if 9981 plus 1601
is equal to two nine five seven
then using the same pattern
what is one zero eight zero
plus nine one six eight equal to
now some of you may point out that these
kinds of puzzles could be ambiguous and
they might have several possible answers
but on the show they didn't have a
chance to argue with the judges
they simply tried to solve it in a very
good-hearted spirit
and they wanted to find the simple rule
to get the correct answer
so can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so what's the pattern
it is to rotate the numbers being added
by 180 degrees and then add those two
numbers
so we take 9981
and 1601
and now let's rotate them 180 degrees
we now end up with 1091 plus
1866 and if we add these two numbers we
get two thousand nine hundred and fifty
seven
so that's the rule
now let's use it to solve the problem
we take 1080
and 9168
and rotate this by 180 degrees
we end up with 8916
plus
801
and when we add these numbers we get the
correct answer of 9717.
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog
mindyourdecisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic or puzzle you can email me
presh mindyourdecisions.com
and you can catch me on social media
either at mind your decisions or at
presh talwalkar